melissa is with us
in las vegas to start off this hour hi
melissa how are you
good how are you better than i deserve
what's up
so back in march i was one of the people
that lost their jobs to covid
and um fortunately we
weren't in debt other than our mortgage
so
buckled up between my husband always
being the breadwinner anyway
just use your every dollar app um really
focused on budget
and we've actually been able to um to
save eight months
for an emergency fund wow good for you
yeah yeah as a family of six
not easy but now we're to the point
where
january is january of this year and i've
talked to my husband about some goals i
might have this year
in terms of home improvements um you
know
maybe a vacation down the road after
being on lockdown this whole time
and um he's like let's just keep
stashing it away let's just keep
stashing it away
and um it's sitting in a
regular savings account number one i
don't know where else to plant it
but number two um how do you get over
that kind of
guilt that we've done so well um
when you see others not doing as well
and at what point do you
relax and take your foot off that gas
and
you know enjoy some of that really good
questions i'm so proud of you
absolutely what a great job yeah yeah
yeah let me ask you this are both of you
all back to work
right now i'm not working
um the field that i'm in um vegas being
a hospitality industry
it's just not there yeah yeah for sure
okay well here's the thing there's a
couple answers to your question
uh you had two or three questions number
one uh the first three baby steps
one through three are with gazelle
intensity
and that's what you've done and that's
not doing anything that's not going out
to eat
it's not going on a vacation it's not
buying anything we're getting out of
debt and getting the emergency fund in
place
those foundational items are an
emergency until you get them done
then when you hit baby steps four five
six you let your foot off the gas
and you go from intense to intentional
okay and what that means is you don't do
anything by accident
but you allow yourself to do some
different things like for instance you
could go out to eat then
for instance you could save up beyond
the emergency fund
and buy a car or go on vacation if you
wanted uh that kind of a thing
meanwhile you're starting your
retirement you're starting your kids
college
and you're beginning to work down on
your home baby steps four five and six
right
and uh so from intense to intentional
and that's where you are
your emergency fund sitting in a savings
is fine you can put it in a money market
it's never going to earn much money
anthony and i always tell people it is
not an investment
it is insurance it's not there to make
you wealthy it's there to protect the
things that make you wealthy so don't
expect that eight thousand dollars to
make you rich
and you really don't need to pile up
more than that if that's three to six
months of expenses
right any piling up you do beyond that
no we have eight months of expenses okay
you have too much
you have two months yes that's where
we're at okay
set aside six months in a separate
account
just for emergencies and don't expect it
to do anything except sit there it's
your umbrella
in the corner you don't need to get it
out of the corner unless it rains
right right and then i would take that
two months for you to answer the next
part of your question is
when do we have a good time like when
can we really enjoy it so i would take
that
one month and enjoy it then take the
other month and look into
investing it but i think you have worked
hard throughout the whole 2021
you went over and beyond but you're
right i think like dave said
be intentional and i think sometimes we
have to be intentional and enjoy
some of the fruit of our labor and so i
would take that one month
uh maybe just take your family out let
y'all just breathe stick within that
budget
but then make sure you're still doing
baby steps four five and six
during this time as well you know the
way the brain works
it's kind of like a pendulum if you
think if you think most people are all
the pendulums all the way to the left
they're disorganized there's no
intentionality
they just stuff happens to them they
don't happen to it and they wonder why
they're broke
right then when you swing it all the way
over to the right
that's gazelle intense and we're beans
and rice
rice and brains we're not doing anything
except piling up debt right
and now all i'm saying is swing it back
to the middle never go all the way back
to the left
the middle is just being intentional but
not
intense and that's where sharon and i
have lived for many many years
and the amazing thing is you can build a
tremendous amount of wealth and be
tremendously generous
in the intentional phase you don't have
to say gazelle intends to become wealthy
you do need to go gazelle intense to get
the mess cleaned up number one and
number two to carve new grooves in your
brain
because the old grooves in your brain
that most people use are stupid yes
and they don't work right and that's
what you did by
this this period this year prove to
yourself and to each other
that we can do this money thing
right right but you can't you can't
sprint
a marathon and you've been sprinting you
sprint the first
you know mile here but then you gotta
let up and get into a rhythm
and that that's where we do when we go
across baby step three so that's really
really good question as far as
all the other people and where they are
the guilt about that
dave i i just be grateful for where i'm
at and acknowledge where they are
but at the end of the day i'm grateful
that i can take care of myself
and my family and i serve and help
whenever i can
yeah what i don't like is dave ramsey
followers on social media
trashing people who aren't doing it
all you gotta do is just go hey i'm
doing it this is what i'm doing
all you do is talk about you you don't
have to go fix
everybody else and if they don't win
it's
most likely i mean there's several
reasons people don't win with money
most of them are our own fault most of
them are the person in my mirror
sometimes there's outside forces that
impact it also
but most of the problems with my money
in my life are caused by
me
and that's that's the thing so you can't
you know i i
you know because someone didn't have the
advantages
of knowledge that i had you know some
people didn't have the benefit of having
been homeless like you
right living in their car and some
people haven't had the benefit of going
broke like i did
right and holding my baby brand new baby
in my arms not knowing how i'm gonna buy
the food
some people have never had that benefit
and you i say it's a benefit yeah it is
i
i it's a privilege i'm privileged in
that regard you're privileged in the
regard that you lived in the back of
your car
because it changed your life yes yes
forever
yeah it changed your paradigm forever
and not everybody has that benefit some
people had to just live
medium and they never they never get off
a medium because medium's good enough
and here it is dave
the reason why it changed your life
going broke but your life was changed to
change
others yeah her life was changed yes
when she lost her job
there you go and they scared them yes i
got four kids we're going to get on a
plan
and they got and they got eight months
saved now in the middle of a dadgum
pandemic
look at you see now i mean everybody's
got an opportunity to do something it's
just a matter of what and when